um is google shopping even a thing do
people use google shopping
do you engage in that ecosystem and what
is it because it's i find google
shopping so confusing i don't even know
what i'm looking at when i do it
it's just it feels like a search result
but then i find out it might be
clicked ads and paid i think consumers
are very confused by google's
shopping product what is google shopping
product what should it be
those are those are different questions
i mean what should it be
what it should be is they should um
figure out a way to surface the very
best products available
regardless of whether or not somebody
has paid an ad for it
and make that available to consumers and
then
allow advertising around it so you get a
genuine search result that reflects
here's the best based on
all of the special magic that we have at
google right
what it is is i think it only includes
people who've paid for ads i think it's
effectively a
a paid listing sort of compendium so
you know you go to google shopping and
you see here are the 40 people who have
bid on this keyword and want to to sell
a product um
but you know i i can't guess what
google's thinking
yeah and that's the reason i ask you is
because you're an expert on it
and you're confused by it and i'm a
neophyte with a lot of experience in
startups and i'm totally confused by it
and
i i've never been able to get an answer
from google like what exactly are they
trying to accomplish here
i think they're just trying to get 75
cents a click and they phone it in